actually people say I am the best boss
they've ever had
the world's greatest boss okay
they go um
Michael we have never worked in a place
like this before
I mean you uh are a riot
um
you get the best out of us and I say
well the case of Ross are wrong you know
and if it's true
awesome
what is que sera
well it's kind of it's it it's kind of a
non-sequitur
I've been told it's kind of
you know kind of filler words have you
ever heard of filler words it's kind of
it's kind of like that you know
um Que Sera Sera
um
if I had to Define what it meant I'd say
um
what what context did I use HSN so we
have the entire floor so this is my
kingdom far as the eye can see ah
this is our receptionist Pam
bam Pam Beasley uh Pam has been with us
um for forever right Pam well I don't
know if you think she's cute now you
should have seen her a couple of years
ago all right all right what uh any
messages
um
yeah just a fax oh
damn this is from corporate how many
times have I told you that there's a
special filing cabinet for things from
corporate called the waste paper basket
look at that
oh look at that face people say I am the
best boss
they go God we've never worked in a
place like this before you're hilarious
and you get the best out of us
um
I think that pretty much sums it up
I found it at Spencer Gifts
uh I'm a sales rep
which means that my job is to speak to
clients on the phone about quantity
type of paper
uh
whether we can supply it to them whether
they can
pay for it
and
I'm boring myself just talking about
to be honest it's uh you know
[Music]
um no gifts for you
my job is to speak to clients on the
phone about
uh quantities and type of
copier paper
you know whether we can supply it to
them whether they can
pay for it and
um
I'm I'm boring myself just talking about
this I hope they get rid of me
because then I might actually get off my
ass and do something because I don't
think it's many little girls dreams to
grow up and be a receptionist
and I don't know what I'm gonna do but
whatever it is it's got to be a career
move not just another arbitrary job and
Jim's advice was that it's better to be
at the bottom of a ladder that you want
to climb than halfway up when you don't
I don't think it would be the worst
thing if they let me go
because then I might
I just I don't think it's many little
girls dream to be a receptionist
I like to do illustrations
um
mostly watercolor
few oil pencil
Jim thinks they're good
urine is sterile
okay
that's a fact did you know that when you
were in the field you can clean a wound
by whizzing on it
true it is in the first aid guidebook
from the American Red Cross Association
so it's totally unfair for me to get in
trouble for whizzing in the sink
hold on hold on Judge is in session what
is the problem here
you put my stuff in jello again
that's real professional thanks it's the
third time and it wasn't funny the first
time it's okay here uh but people
sometimes take advantage because it's so
relaxed I'm a volunteer sheriff's deputy
on the weekends
and you cannot screw around there
sort of one of the roles hey maybe yeah
uh yeah would you mind if I wanted for a
drink with these guys
no no this Scotty let's go home do you
mind if I go out for a drink with these
guys
no come
let's get out of here go home
okay um
I'm gonna be a few I can't tell it's
only
20 past five I still have to do my faxes
you know what you should uh you should
come with us
because we're you know we're all going
out and could be a good chance for you
to see what people are like outside of
the office you know I think it could be
fun no it sounds sounds good oh no
seriously we gotta get going yeah yeah
um
what's in the uh what's in the back
still I've talked over there no
definitely all right dude awesome
we'll do
Michael
oh we have to sooner or later yes but
right now what we have to decide is do
you fold Stanford people into this
Branch or vice versa
just before lunch that would be great
corporate really doesn't interfere with
me at all um Jan Levinson Gould hello
yes I call her Hillary Rodham Clinton
right not to her face because uh well
not because I'm scared of her
because I'm not
but um
yeah
all right was there anything you wanted
to add to the agenda
me no get in agenda
I'm what I'm sorry I didn't get any
agenda well ifx went over to you this
morning really because I didn't uh I
didn't did we get a fax this morning
yeah the one the red white
why is it in my hand
because the company runs on efficiency
of communication right
um so what's the problem Pam why I
didn't uh want to get it
you put it in the garbage can that was a
special filing cabinet
uh that was a joke
that was a joke that was actually my
brothers and it was It was supposed to
be with bills and it doesn't work great
with facts yeah yeah thanks
okay so since the last meeting Alan and
the board have decided that we can't
justify Scranton Ranch and a Stanford
Branch oh oh okay no Michael don't no no
no no no no this is good this is good
this is fine listen okay don't panic oh
yeah
I've spoken to Josh and Stanford I've
told him the same as you and it's up to
either you or him to convince me that
your branch could incorporate the other
okay no problem this does however mean
that there's going to be downsizing me
no want to hear that Jan because
downsizing is a [ __ ] it is a real [ __ ]
and I wouldn't uh wish that on Josh's
men I certainly wouldn't wish it on my
men or women present company excluded
uh is Josh concerned about downsizing
himself
not downsizing himself but is he
concerned about downsize we play hard
and we work hard sometimes we uh
probably play hard when we should be
working hard but that's probably my
fault but
fire me
50 talking Chester Avenue talking
Triplex talking converting is that her
hey guys say something hello hi I'm Mark
hi Pam hello I'm the uh horrible boss
around here but uh please don't hire
Jamie Foxx to kill me Django
oh
I don't agree with the use of the n-word
in that movie it's too soon
I'm Pam oh hi they call me Marky Mark
around here because here at Simon Realty
We Are One fog air bonds
come on you guys raise the roof when I
say that I what are you all temps again
today
let's go Gangnam Style he's her Gangnam
Style he knows it right that's because
he's American this is Carl
uh he's from here he's from
our neck of the woods but Gangnam Style
is great isn't it
oh my God he's Michael Scott